as we concluded a radical change was
needed a brave new world a completely
new approach to building applications
needed to be developed that could scale
to meet the demands of the rapidly
growing internet
now the key step to building a scalable
system is you need to decouple it from
executing on a single computer you
design a scale-out architecture as your
application scales outside the scope of
a single computer and this distributed
architecture needs to be a so-called
share nothing architecture meaning that
it must not depend on any shared
resources that can become the bottleneck
this way if your application needs to
scale you can just provide more
computers to provide the additional
capacity required
that means you can run your application
on
all the things
and to get even more flexibility the
concept of virtual machines was born
which enables you to decouple a physical
machine from the application execution
machine this had great flexibility gain
since the infrastructure turned virtual
you would now run your scale out
application on several virtual machines
instead of physical computers
problem solved right you can now scale
indefinitely by adding these standard
building blocks of performance that your
application can utilize and you have
decoupled your application from a
specific execution machine
great
now only one question remains how do you
design your application to be able to
scale like this